Let's go next to our caller from the six zero
eight area code. Who is calling today from
six zero eight.
Hello David. This is Jack.
Hey Jack, what's up?
Okay, so there's this thing. I would go to
a college and I'm a liberal in my college
and I see a lot of Trump supporters in my
college and it seems the reason for that is
because they hate the regressive left and
they don't really understand much about other
issues and they just get droven driven further
to the right because of the left end. They're
a social justice warrior. You know how that
is. So I just wondering what are your thoughts
on that and how can I talk to a Trump supporter
that just hates the left because of that and
want to offer them a new perspective.
So listen, here's the unfortunate reality,
and I addressed this a couple of weeks ago,
a little bit when I did an audience question
about what happened to the, uh, anti S J w
movement. Because the reality is that there
has always been a sliver of the left that
is obsessed with identity politics to an unhealthy
degree, for example, right? Or whatever, whatever
you want to talk, like whatever slice you're
referring to, that people at your college
are sick of, that has existed for a long time.
They became a target of the outright and of
so-called free speech movements on the right
for a little while, and they got some traction
from it. And then it sort of started to fade
and then it became less of a thing. So I think
the most thing in my mind to engage with people,
uh, on, on the right is show them that the
people that have been out there fear-mongering
about so-called SJWs are, uh, are lying to
them.
They are not honestly representing that that
is a tiny fraction of the left that does not
represent the big ideas of the left in any
way. Um, and try to get them to see that they've
been bamboozled by whoever it is that came
to the campus or whose videos they watched
on YouTube that convinced them that this is
a big problem. Is it a problem? Sure. I mean
like, it exists and I've spoken out against
it, but they don't have a controlling stake
in the left at this point in time. They don't
have a controlling stake in the narrative.
And, uh, it's, it's, uh, it's sad actually
that a lot of people get sucked into these
echo chambers, um, when we're really talking
about a very small sliver of the left. That's
the reality.
Yeah. And I actually liked, I talked to these
people that say they're conservative and they
seem just to hate SJWs. But when I talked
to them about individual issues, they're liberal,
like they're liberal when it comes to gun
control, when it comes to healthcare, when
it comes to, when it comes to foreign policy,
it's just that the fact of those, those SJWs
is just make them go right because they just
can't stand it.
Yup. Absolutely. Yeah. You're pointing this
out perfectly, which is an issue on issues.
There's no reason for them to be supporting
Donald Trump and it's a, it's a horrible propaganda
campaign that worked pretty well for awhile,
but I have to tell you, I think it is starting,
its effectiveness has started to wane and
hopefully we'll continue to.
All right David, that's really all I had to
ask you about. Um,
all right, very good. Thank you so much for
the call. Yeah, I appreciate you calling in.